so today we start with last night's
election results which are i mean i'll
skip to the conclusion they're an
absolute disaster for democrats they
could spell major trouble
for the democrats and for the left to
the extent that the left exists in the
united states through the democratic
party that's an issue we can talk about
as well um there are a range of opinions
about how much of a disaster last
night's results are and that's fine
but it's not good it's not good the big
race the major race that so many were
looking at was the virginia
gubernatorial race
where the democratic governor ralph
northam who won by nine in 2017 in
virginia
was term limited out two contenders were
vying to replace ralph northam it was
democrat terry mcauliffe and republican
glenn younkin now the polls were very
tight over the last three weeks i
continued saying it's basically even
could be plus one or two in either
direction terry mcauliffe a completely
milk-toast democrat not particularly
inspiring in any way not particularly
distressing in any way other than sort
of like distressing in the sense of is
this guy really going to inspire people
to turn out and vote glenn younkin on
the other hand a truly disgusting
radical republican
playing up cultural issues as expected
and as republicans have been doing over
the last many years and yunkin won young
can won now interestingly you know let's
put aside for a second
no republicans are claiming fraud that
i'm aware of in any of these races from
yesterday even though you had some
republicans saying it looks like
democrats are stealing votes in virginia
and if mcauliffe wins we'll probably say
there was fraud and now they're all
silent
i mean we can't even deal with that
today because it's so absurd but as the
results went as the results came in
early in the in the night last night um
glenn younkin got up to even a 10 10 and
a half point lead i think at one point
as the more left-leaning counties with
large populations were counted the lead
tightened and tightened but it ended up
being a roughly two-point win in
virginia for the republican glenn
younkin now the scary part the question
we were talking about yesterday
including on our live stream with many
of our viewers from virginia and it's
been written about extensively in the
first few hours of today by all of the
typical political voices
is the virginia gubernatorial election
at bellwether for 2022.
some say yes definitely this spells
disaster for democrats in 2022 others
say no
some say well maybe somewhat but not
totally
what there is no way to deny
is that bellwether aside for 2022
when the last race for virginia governor
was won by nine by a democrat and now
it's won by two by a republican that's
an 11-point swing in one cycle that's
not good for democrats in virginia
period now in a moment we'll look at the
historical
it's not uncommon
that in virginia the governor's race
goes the opposite way that the white
house went in the previous election
that's not uncommon but it still doesn't
bode well for 2022 even if you concede
that it's a historical pattern so we're
going to talk about that virginia was a
state that we were hoping
was leaning more and more left
and republicans want it republicans want
it and they won it with a really simple
tactic and this is important to
understand
democrats are not very good at messaging
it's almost cliche to say it we've done
so many interviews about it we've talked
to thomas frank about it we've talked to
george lakoff we've talked about it in
so many different ways democrats are not
very good at messaging in particular
republicans know the messaging that will
get people to vote and that will get
people to vote for them
it doesn't matter if it's based in fact
it doesn't matter if it's totally wrong
they understand republicans that if they
get their base angry enough
and scared enough
it will motivate their voters to go to
the polls there is just no way and i
hate that i mean this is not even a
political thing this is almost
psychology sociology
there is no way that democrats can get
the same amount of motivation and energy
to get their base to turn out by
pitching green energy
equal uh equality of opportunity
and all these things that actually
matter
compared to
how republicans do it with fear
uh and with um
anger
and republicans did it in virginia with
talk of
fixing education and getting rid of
critical race theory the very same
republicans think about the absurdity
from a values standpoint the same
republicans who claim that as a value
they don't want government doing too
much they want to limit the areas that
government is even involved
they got people angry and afraid enough
to go out and vote by saying we're going
to get in there and tell schools what to
teach that was a big part of glenn
younkin's campaign and the people around
yunkan interviews with voters republican
voters in virginia showed they were
voting yunkan many of them
because they wanted him to deal with
education and critical race theory it's
absurd it's absurd and it's counter to
their stated values but it worked and
they won the race then we had the
gubernatorial race in new jersey now it
was believed to be a very safe seat for
the incumbent democratic governor phil
murphy in the blue state of new jersey
where joe biden defeated donald trump
easily in 2022 by 16. biden beat trump
by 16 in jersey in 2020
and phil murphy did jump out to a big
lead up front
but then as the night went on and we
watched the results come in the
republican challenger gained and gained
and eventually took a two-point lead now
as more votes came in overnight as of i
just looked at it and hopefully this is
not outdated by the time you listen to
today's show but as of just 15 minutes
ago the race has not been called
and with 92 reporting phil murphy is
back in the lead but by 0.06 percent
that's not 0.6 percent
it's
0.06 about 1300 votes 8
of the ballots still to be counted now
if democrats lose the new jersey
governorship
it's a disaster
even if murphy wins but by less than not
even less than a point less than a tenth
of a point is what the margin is right
now to massive swing in 2017 phil murphy
won by 15 points in new jersey then
biden won easily in 2020 and now phil
murphy's trying to eke out a win by a
tenth of a point as of 15 minutes ago so
no matter who wins republicans closed a
massive gap in a very very blue state
that also doesn't bode well if you were
of the mindset well virginia doesn't
tell us much by itself well it's not by
itself look at virginia and new jersey
and then what else we're going to talk
about more of the results on the bonus
show today
some of the results very much expected
uh democrat eric adams won new york city
mayor a left-leaning candidate michelle
wu one boston mayor and then
you know not surprisingly self-described
socialist india walton did not win the
buffalo mayorship uh lost by a lot by 17
points to a write-in candidate i know
that many progressives were very
interested in that race
it is not super shocking to me
that a self-described socialist
did not get elected mayor of buffalo new
york joe biden won buffalo easily
but democratic voters are not
necessarily socialist voters and that's
not shocking there and we'll look at
some of the other results on the bonus
show today now i do think it's important
to restate
that in a lot of ways this was a turnout
victory for republicans there were
anecdotally republicans saying my
democratic friends are voting for
republicans this time around in jersey
in virginia in some other races and
anecdotally there are always examples of
everything some republicans who vote
democrat democrats who vote republican
etc
but really it was using fear and anger
to get turnout for example terry
mcauliffe actually outperformed joe
biden among some groups sahil kapoor
from nbc news pointed this out in a
tweet and said you know among white
women college graduates
biden got 58 of that group in 2020
whereas terry mcauliffe got 62 percent
of that group in 2020 mcauliffe built
the lead
that joe biden had among white women
with college degrees
but it just wasn't enough because other
groups did not turn out in the numbers
that terry mcauliffe needed so
non-college white women
voted for yunkan by an even bigger
margin
than they voted for donald trump so what
we had was an exaggeration of the 2020
results with the turnout favoring
republicans now
does that mean 2022 looks less bad not
really
this could point to a very bad 2022
because midterms are often turnout
elections so democrats need to number
one do some stuff now but what i mean
that sounds silly
they need to get some things done that
they can point to and say hey look at
these things that we actually did you've
you've got to do some things and we're
going to talk about spending an
infrastructure bill a little bit later
but saying that terry mcauliffe simply
ran a bad campaign is myopic new jersey
shouldn't be this close pennsylvania
supreme court won by republicans
if democrats don't want to accept this
as a wake-up call publicly to save face
okay i mean you know there's debate do
you ever really admit that it was a
disaster for you maybe you don't
but privately democrats had better see
this as a wake-up call and it's almost
more difficult without trump on the
ballot as i've said before
it's harder to say
um even though we haven't done much vote
for us anyway when trump's not there
when it's trump
uh when it's overtly a referendum on
trump the we aren't trump message makes
more sense because trump is such a train
wreck even if you don't have that much
that you've done to point to
you're not trump you're not crazy in
that way
when there's no trump it's well we're
better than these other republicans who
also aren't trump it's weak in terms of
messaging it's weak in terms of framing
and there's a very good article in the
atlantic this morning by elaine godfrey
and russell berman called if democrats
can lose virginia
they can lose almost anywhere which
points out that yunkan
neither repudiated nor embraced trump he
really didn't do either he he actually
kind of played coy with trump and we
talked about this all along and
republicans ended up winning that race
now let let me now after everything i've
said about how disastrous this could be
let me just present to you the least
disastrous interpretation just so you
know that there is one and it would be
the following
it's really common
that in virginia the governorship goes
to the opposition party when there's a
new president so when carter won in the
next election virginia gubernatorial
went to republicans when reagan won it
then went to democrats when bush senior
won it then went to democrats when
clinton won it switched to republicans
when george w bush won it switched to
democrats when obama won switched to
republicans and now uh and same with
trump switched to democrats and now we
have biden wins and it switches to
republicans so if you want to point to
that and say that's how virginia works
it's not really a big concern
you can find a justification
in the history to make that claim but
with the new jersey numbers
not looking good
and with some of these other things not
looking good i certainly wouldn't be
taking that chance and it's a completely
plausible scenario can't yet say likely
a lot of things need to happen we've got
a year until the 2020 midterms which i
think are really going to get going in
late february early march
it could be an absolute bloodbath for
democrats in 2022
if biden then does not run for
re-election which is plausible
um and then you've got you know like a
not super popular kamala harris as the
nominee
there could be a scenario and i always
want to balance being realistic
but not being alarmist but not
downplaying things
we could have a scenario where 2022 is a
disaster for democrats
2024 is a disaster for democrats and you
end up with democrats trying to take
control back of something in 2026
after republicans have gotten
a lot of opportunity to do some serious
damage to this country damage that will
take you know
to 2030 to start undoing i mean it's a
it's a grim and dark potential path and
that's why it's important to see every
single one of these elections in context
so let me know your thoughts let me know
your interpretation we're gonna have
more on some of the minor races uh on
today's bonus show which you can get
access to by becoming a member at
joinedpakman.com and you can find me on
twitter at deepakman and let me know
your interpretation your analysis of
yesterday's election results
one of our sponsors is kamikoto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan i've been a
big fan of japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing i've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikodo and through this
partnership they're doing with us
camikoto is giving you 50 off on top of
their other special offers just go to
camikoto.com pacman and use the code
pacman for fifty dollars off the link is
down below